hey everyone i am really excited to have
in front of me the chessup board
this is a brand new smart chess board
with a ton of cool features
it has wechats and chess.com integration
it has an interactive assistance mode
where squares will light up to show you
not only legal moves but also best moves
and blunders and everything in between
there's also different levels of ai
ranging from 100 elo to all the way over
3000 hilo so very strong version of
stockfish and this board is available
for pre-order
uh their worldwide launch will be in may
and full disclosure i am a chessup
affiliate so that means if you click the
link in the video description
you can you can order the board use
coupon code rosen to save some money and
it's also supporting my content as well
and in this video i filmed with tatev
abrahamian who actually works for bright
labs which makes the chess up board
and uh as we're gonna see i tried to
take down the chessboard and it was a
super fun game and i hope you guys enjoy
the video let's just get into the game
and hopefully i can i can beat the chess
board
so good luck i like when you point at me
when you say i'm playing the ai
yeah uh you'll you'll be playing the
moves for the ai so
um
yeah so i'm not actually playing i'm
just moving you're just whatever happens
it's not my fault yeah okay
interesting opening i'm not expecting
that move
wow it's playing like we're in
there yeah it's kind of a third london
anti-london opening
okay
so the only assistance i get is uh what
legal moves there are so no legal moves
with my king
okay let's control the center
this is very interesting opening so far
have the two bishops the power of your
bishop
okay um
which way do i want to cast i'll play
this move
oh
aggressive
so this bishop i think i can see i can
see the problems in the future yeah okay
oh let's train a little bit
wow
okay
very positional game so far
i see your plans
i see his plans
and that's gonna be like something
completely different
um
look at this there should be a feature
where the board like talks to you and
trash talks in your while it crushes
your soul
wow h5
[Music]
i'm not good at trash checking what i
could have done but
yeah you're too nice to trash sock
i'm going to defend this poncho now okay
queen c2
wow
[Music]
it's playing like really esque right
it's just coming up with like weird
moves h56
and very quickly too it is annoying i
feel slightly bedazzled okay let's play
this move
oh wow
it's not easy too hard for the bishop
[Music]
it's 94 i think no
[Music]
how do you feel about your position
i feel like
i was hoping you wouldn't see the
threats or it wouldn't see the threats
maybe next time she'll play against
okay let's castle
i'm like nervous for both sides in this
position
like if i was playing this over the
board
dude
i don't think it works so now let's
uh slow play a little bit
[Music]
oh that's a good move
okay
[Music]
you can't see anyone before i know i
know
oh no my pawn
i feel like you're getting outplayed
now my position doesn't feel good
or smell good
i'm gonna point out all the pawn
weaknesses
all my pawns that can't move
okay v5
oh my mouth now you have to worry about
this person
i want to just sack stuff and mates but
it's not easy so i think you might start
sucking against your will you know like
all these problems
yeah that's not making me feel bad
okay
[Music]
wait a minute
wait a minute
tactics you're getting muted
oh no
okay
finishing off
i feel so sad
you got too excited you thought you
tried the computer okay so this part
will be cool
uh okay the lights make me slightly
happier
i'm glad to hear that
good game
okay so that was
a little bit sad but hopefully it goes
to show that
you have to be careful messing with the
chest up ai
um
so i hope you guys enjoyed that video
if you're interested in learning more
about chessup and even pre-ordering this
product
links will be in the description and if
you want to see more chessup content let
me know there's a lot of different
features we can do with this board but i
think we'll save it for future videos so
i'll see you guys then